you know that i prefer to focus almost
100 of the time on things happening in
this country and to this country
especially those things which may most
immediately impact your family and your
children um those kinds of issues serve
as the nucleus of this show and it's not
because events across the world are
unimportant in the grand scheme it's
just that we can only focus our
attention on a limited number of things
and solve a limited number of problems
and so i choose
those things and problems which are
closest to us
as it happens
our own society is in the grip of
several crises all at once
cataclysms which are only
accelerating the fall and decay of our
once great civilization i don't think we
have the luxury to spend very much time
trying to fix the world's problems
even it would be even if it would be
otherwise wise and noble to try which it
isn't in my view
our attention is urgently needed in our
own communities and households we can't
afford to take the eye off of that ball
we can't wander off into the wilderness
searching for far-off dragons to slay
because because we have more than enough
of them here
though they may take different forms
from what you find elsewhere on earth
all of that is a long way of saying
that the situation in afghanistan is not
the sort of thing i would normally talk
about on this show
as you've heard i'm sure biden moved to
finally withdraw our troops from
afghanistan but apparently had no real
plan for evacuating everybody safely the
taliban moved in took over the country
in about two days while the afghan army
and government fled into the night
like real heroes
now afghanistan is back in the spot it
was in 20 years ago only it's worse
really because the taliban claims
possession of all of the munitions and
artillery that we left behind
um
so
with all of that going on i'm going to
make an exception to my normal rule rule
at least for today
and offer a few comments about all of
this
i'm not an expert
on afghanistan but then again the
experts on afghanistan much like the
public health experts here in the u.s
have largely created the very problems
that they're supposed to be the experts
on solving so it once again falls to
rational people to use common sense to
throw to sort through all of this and
that's what i'll try to do now on that
end
three primary points i think need to be
made
first of all
there's no question that biden's
withdrawal has been handled so poorly
that to use a word like poorly is to
pay biden an undue compliment
the president of the united states who
may or may not be conscious and
cognizant right now who knows
is hunkered down in camp david and
refusing to address the american people
or explain his strategy i mean last
night it was announced that even biden's
press secretary pasaki will be mia for
the next week
you know the the people that try to send
her an email got got a form response
saying i'll be back in about a week
hope there's nothing urgent that you
need
the biden regime is literally in hiding
as the u.s installed afghan regime
surrenders the country to the taliban
and americans in the country are left
stranded
so the only real question now is whether
biden knew that it would go this way and
lied
or if he's really so clueless and
mentally degraded at this point that he
believed the nonsense he spewed at a
press conference just a month ago let's
listen to that again this was back
in the in early july here's what he said
about leaving afghanistan and how he
expected it would go let's watch
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as quipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable
mr president thank you very much your
own intelligence community has assessed
that the afghan government will likely
collapse that's not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion so what is the level of
confidence that they have that it will
not collapse
the afghan government
and leadership has to come together
they clearly have the capacity
to sustain the government in place
yeah about that
well the afghan government did collapse
and the afghan middle military didn't
even so much as put up a fight
they came together on the road as they
were getting their asses out of there
um i i'm not sure if a single shot was
actually fired in defense of kabul it
was always clear to all intelligent
people that the withdraw from
afghanistan
would play out this way
biden should have built a plan which
accounts for that but instead he denied
the obvious facts on the ground and
planned for a leisurely peaceful exit
one where i guess the afghan government
and military waves goodbye to our troops
as they leave and shouts we'll take care
of things here you all have a safe trip
home now
the taliban look on from their caves
decide that it'll be rude to move in and
undo all of america's hard work over the
past two decades now we're not going to
do that that would be you know that's
not fair
that's what biden imagined or at least
wanted us to imagine
i'm willing to believe that he himself
actually did imagine that given that his
brain is operating at 40 capacity at
best
and was never terribly powerful even
with all of its batteries fully charged
but the people actually running the
administration those who are really in
charge of our government and we don't
know exactly who those people are by
design
knew that it would be a bud bloodbath on
the way out and we're apparently okay
with that
for this reason much of the criticism
that biden is sustaining right now is
completely justified and 100 warranted
there are even calls for him to resign
which are also warranted though we
should always keep in mind
that you know what's waiting in the
wings will not be by any stretch of the
imagination and improvement
but second point with all that said
many of the people on the right and on
the left who are complaining about the
exit from afghanistan are upset
apparently
that we are exiting from afghanistan at
all
for these people the issue is not just
the manner of the exit
but the fact of the exit
they believe that even after 20 years
america still owes a debt to afghanistan
and must remain there indefinitely
and there and from what i've noticed by
the way um
there are a lot of people on this side
of the debate
who like
up to a month ago
were claiming to be non-interventionist
there are many republicans right now and
again we're leaving yes yes it was it
was handled poorly i got that
moving on from that discussion
there are many so-called or or
alleged non-interventionist
conservatives
who have completely dropped that now
just like that
you know trump made it cool to be a
non-interventionist conservative and so
a lot of conservatives especially in the
republican party and prominent ones in
media kind of pretended to be that
and now many of them are fully back on
board with no no let's stay there
forever i mean let's literally stay
there forever yes
and many of the people on this side of
the debate like to point out that
america still has bases in countries
like japan and germany
why can't we maintain a presence in
afghanistan as well
well these people are
are incredibly wrong
for these reasons leaving aside for a
moment the way that the withdrawal was
handled again it is inarguably true that
there needed to be a withdrawal
yes we maintain bases in japan and
germany you could make a very compelling
argument that we shouldn't have them
there either especially as those
countries are more than capable of
defending themselves but there's also a
significant difference here
japan and germany are countries
actual real nations
afghanistan is not
afghanistan is a medieval third world
hell pit with no will to exist on its
own accord i mean think about it we
armed and equipped the afghan military
for 20 years
biden claims that it was 300 000 strong
that figure is probably false like
everything else biden says but let's use
it for the sake of argument i mean it
was certainly large at any rate it was a
large army
much larger than the taliban forces and
yet the afghan army after 20 years of
training
folded in two days to a gang of
seventh century terrorists who they
outnumbered three to one
the army and the government surrendered
gave up
abandoned ship immediately
without even a symbolic attempt at
fighting
back not so much as firing a shot in
most cases they just left
what does that tell us
it tells us that afghanistan is a
country that we built
but we built it like a deck of cards
it needs our constant presence our
sacrifice and blood and treasure simply
to exist
the whole country is like the highway
system in afghanistan that we spent
billions constructing did you know that
you spent billions on on building
highways in afghanistan you did
and then the afghan government and the
afghan people they let it fall
immediately into disrespect disrepair it
it's now crumbled and largely unusable
because the people we built it for
refuse to maintain it
and that's the story of afghanistan it
has always been the story
forcing this
country on people who don't want it have
no interest in it
here's a point that few people will make
but i will even if it sounds harsh i
want you to look at this footage from
the
kabul airport
here it is here
people are are fleeing you've got
fleeing afghans trying to climb onto the
evacuation plane as it speeds down the
runway which by the way is
not a good plan of action
apparently some of them actually you can
see them there they jumped on
you could see them holding to the side
of the plane
while it was taking off
and then fell to their deaths as the
plane took off which of course that's
how that was going to work out now it's
a tragic scene shortly but it's tragic
in more than just the obvious way
because what else do you notice about
this crowd
what do you see or more specifically
what do you not see
women
children
these are almost all men
and you can look at any of the footage
of these you know stampeding hordes of
people trying to get out of afghanistan
look at any of the footage and you're
going to see predominantly almost
exclusively men
mostly of fighting age from the looks of
it i mean these aren't elderly men
sprinting down the airport runway
so mostly young men scrambling to leave
just as the army left
can i ask the impolite question
why aren't these men fighting for their
country
we're now going to be guilted now into
accepting thousands of them as refugees
not concerned that there could easily be
taliban hiding in their midst but more
to the point
men of afghanistan do not seem willing
to fight to protect the families of
afghanistan
and yet our men should
our young men should die on afghan
afghanistan soil to do what afghan men
will not do
refuse to do
it bears repeating over and over again
the afghan army
and the afghan men they were not
defeated they just gave up
right away that's it
this is what it comes down to
we cannot hold into existence a country
which does not want to exist
we cannot task ourselves with the
responsibility of sustaining nations
which lack the willpower to sustain
themselves
we especially can't do that while our
own nation struggles in its own way to
exist
and that brings me to the third point
maybe you remember this tweet from the
u.s embassy in kabul
just just two months ago this is what
they were tweeting
says the month of june is recognized as
lgbti pride month the united states
respects the dignity and equality of
lgbti people and celebrates their
contributions to the society
we remain committed to supporting civil
rights of minorities including lgbti
persons
this is what our ruling class has become
this is the kind of empire they seek to
build this is what they want to export
out into the world when they're not at
home chasing down you know other terror
threats like anti-massacres and old
ladies who trespass in the capital
and when they're not on tv preaching
about racial diversity and cultural
sensitivity
i mean one seriously wonders whether our
military left copies of white fragility
and you know i am jazz at the embassy
for the taliban when they took over i
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
plan i would not be surprised
the point is that even if you're a fan
of nation building and colonization and
that's what we did in afghanistan if you
support
what we did in afghanistan and you want
to see more of it you are by definition
a colonizer
but even if you like the idea in theory
the fact is that our government in our
military as it is currently run and
constructed
is not capable of building and
sustaining a global empire
a government waving rainbow flags and a
military indoctrinated into lgbt
and critical race theory propaganda
cannot be an imperial force even if it
wants to be
most of the people defending american
imperialism abroad
seem to want to pretend that we're still
the country we were 100 years ago we're
not
and that brings us back to where we
started
back at home in the throes of our own
crisis
our own struggle to simply exist
a struggle that calls for all hands on
deck
let the afghans fight for afghanistan
if they will not it will fall
already has because they didn't
just as if we don't fight for our own
country
so will it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content